chris webber didn't play any defense
tnt's coverage of the nba playoffs
continues tonight with the triple
headers starting at four
eastern chris webber will be on the call
for game four tonight between the lakers
and the blazers at nine eastern good
morning sea webb how are you
good morning how are you doing today i'm
doing okay why have we seen
these crazy numbers as far as scoring
the highest scoring post season
in the last 35 years well you know i
said before
this whole experience that i thought the
bubble was the great equalizer
what i meant by that was you know the
momentum isn't as tangible you know if
you're a first-year player
uh in the playoffs it's not uh it's not
as
intimidating you don't have thousands of
fans yelling at you uh the
energy you saw porzingis get a technical
in his first game well i expected that
from young guys he's been waiting to be
in the playoffs for five years so
how do you manage that emotion and here
you don't have to along with the travel
you know after games you know usually
last night you have left around 1 30 in
the morning got to a hotel
on the west coast the longest travel 4
30 in the morning had to eat
wake up this morning and have meetings
and so you don't have any of that
everyone has the same routine and i
think that that's allowed for just some
really good play along with this is the
most rested we've ever seen
any players uh head into the playoffs
and i think rest has a lot to do with it
because of the hiatus
explain this to me because i'm still
waiting to find an answer that i never
want the best player on the floor to
have the ball
with the chance to win the game i'd i
would run two people at you i want you
to give up the ball
the clippers allowed to have luca to get
the ball
and then even a switch on defense that
reggie jackson ended up with him i know
that i look at the end result and he
made it
i just don't like single coverage on the
you know great players
and that was my biggest issue i had a
few issues with the clippers but that
one
explain that to me yeah no i agree with
you i just think the fact though that
because
uh kawhi was on him i think it was
miscommunication and
so first of all you're writing your
strategy take it out the hot man's hands
you know but
the problem is on that team you still
have hardaway and others that could
shoot but i'd rather have them shoot
before luca but that switch once you get
into it and and that's the way that it
was and you gotta
look at the brilliance of this move with
it's a move called the hands up and
hands up is when you dribble
you look up and you hesitate and you
keep going and because he can shoot off
the dribble his hands up is crazy you
have to honor every fate that luca has
so one you're right it should have
doubled but when they didn't i thought
reggie jackson played
as good a defense as you could because
you still have to watch out for the pump
faking him leaning into you
that late so um that's what we call good
deed better oh and uh luke is just
uh he's just starting off um starting
off making a little resume for himself
on why he's uh
why he's gonna be a great one pretty
soon explain his greatness
okay um
he's six eight he's strong i'm talking
about he's really strong
he's about 250 uh he can get anywhere he
wants in the paint because he's quick
because of his footwork you don't have
to be fast in this game fast is more for
the john walls and
and the west brooks when you're going
full court he's not that player that's
going to go full court actually he is
all he needs is a screen at the top of
the key
and depending on how high they screen he
can either shoot a 40 foot three
a 30 foot three or he can lay it up he
can finish inside he can
facilitate out of the post when he wants
to he's unselfish and the best thing i
like about her dan
that boy got hard and you see him
talking to them the other day
letting them know so for me old school
that performance and the way that
he was saying i'm here stopped me that
that me
that was that was exciting even when he
made the shot
and it wasn't a crowd to me it was
almost more exciting than the crowd
being there because you really saw the
raw emotion of the team and um
he's he's good but most importantly he's
savvy
he's a leader and he has confidence okay
what do you do
if anything if you're the nba to montrez
harrell who had some things to say
to luca a couple of times during the
previous game
you finally suspend well i think uh
that's something for league office to
talk about i also
think that's the responsibility league
that uh i don't know if we need to see
a player's mouth in slow motion every
time they make a play
um there's a lot of things set up
and it's messed up so first of all
saying stuff is one thing so i don't
want to speak on what he said that's one
thing and it may be a suspension
and secondly i know there were things
that were said just as bad or worse
in every game since i've been here and
it's just been
whose mouth they put the camera on but
what did you face what did you hear when
you played
um ours was more ours was more um
questioning your manhood you know um
ours was more
you know um i i
very honestly i really didn't hear a lot
because i will win a crazy contest
so you don't want to talk to the guy
and um wait wait what do you mean you
would win a crazy contest
well i went to crazy contest it was an
old fred sanford uh
episode where lamont uh uh
or lamont grady together and the mott
had a date
in a bar and this guy was gonna beat him
up and so grady told him listen
just act crazy and lamont was just act
screaming act like he knew karate and
the guy was like i'm not fighting
you crazy so for me it was just that
you know i'm kind of quiet i'll talk
jump on a move but if we really want to
get into talking you don't want to do
that because i will talk to you every
day
for the rest of your life remember every
game and you just don't want that
because the stuff i could pull out
you just don't i mean i've called the
timeout i've been to the worst i
i can i can i can mind game you and so
uh
my thing was um just keep it quiet but
gary payton
he was i used to love playing against
him because he used to talk so much junk
to my players i remember the first game
pager
played and he told
he told pedro if you shoot the ball
again pajama he said shoot the ball
again i'm gonna smack the hell out of
you
and uh i won the crazy contest because i
told coach hey i gotta get you know
kicked out of this game to show pager
that um you know i got us back forever
and um gary just we just went at it and
we had the craziest talking match and
then we went out to dinner
after the game and uh it was a little
wwf when you talk but uh for some guys
if you don't know it's real but you just
got to get through the mental games
we're talking to chris webber turner
sports nba analyst are the clippers in
trouble
yes why well doc rivers told me before
game three that they were lucky to be
tied at one-on-one
um they're in trouble because you know
it is almost like
having a fourth and five and running it
every time and you're on your own
30-yard line
you know how deflating that could be you
know and when they penetrate i mean you
think about it's the best in my opinion
defensive team especially on the
perimeter pat beverly or not
and so the fact that luca has just been
straight up able to dominate kind of
like donovan mitchell
against denver when you have those type
of series and those type of games
um you know la knows that they could
lose
you know pg hasn't really had a good
game in this series
think about this porzingis didn't even
play last game
he's an early game scratch you know so
yeah they're in trouble
they're in a lot of trouble i don't
understand the paul george
situation here is he injured
is there something we don't know about
paul george that he has not been
that great player he was in oklahoma
city it could be
but i don't know what that is um i like
how he's taking responsibility
at least in game one and two and some
guys have slumps you know
i thought he took some really good shots
uh in game three i thought he kept
playing defense and
staying involved but you know i don't
know what it is sometimes uh
some kind guys get the yips in the
playoffs or sometimes they just have a
bad
series but when you have consecutive
series in different years
it you know it does stand out to you and
make you go hey
uh uh what's going on but you know i'm
interested to see tonight we have the
game but after
the game the other day we asked kawhi
you know can you guys win without this
and and i loved his answer he was like
yeah we can win and paul's gonna come
out shooting so
i'm just interested in seeing la to me
has played
hollywood a little bit like when the
lakers didn't have kobe they
were a little too cool and didn't win
and it was like the lake show without
any substance well that seems to be like
what's going on with the clippers now
because they used to come out and get on
you defensively stay on you and
it's just been a different uh team
harold montrez has to get into shape
he's not running out so
um they're definitely in trouble because
dallas is good they have confidence and
they want to prove to the world that um
they can beat
all of our predictions for champions
blazers take game one lakers have come
back and looked like we thought they
would uh
lakers still have issues
i think they're still going to have
issues but they still have lebron so
they're gonna
always have a chance but yeah they have
issues they don't they need shooting
they need perimeter shooting and um
until they find that
uh i would force lebron to keep scoring
or i would double team him and take the
ball out of his hands and just
make the others beat you that that's
what you have to do with lebron on the
floor and so
um yeah that's going to continue to be
an issue and they're going to have to
continue to find ways
uh to overcome their shooting walls
76ers game plan
is it now officially processed because
the process doesn't continue after what
we saw
in the bubble here what's next yeah um
i i think you i think you you blow that
team up
um uh who do you keep
it depends on who the locker room likes
but i don't yeah i mean
you know i just brought this up chris
they brought in al horford they spent al
hor
they spent 100 million dollars on al
horford to come in and be a locker room
presence
an older al horford yes they can't play
that can't play like you used to yeah i
i i questioned that decision then
yeah you think about the celtics made an
offer and they didn't want to see them
go but they were like for that okay
let's see see you later so yeah i think
you have to question some
decision makers even letting reddit go i
mean they really had some
some good pieces there and you think
about it losing
25 games consecutively twice in a season
tanking to get to this point talking
about the process monetizing
the losses and then getting here and it
being this way
it's um really disappointing but i think
you're going to have to make a choice
between simmons and you're going to have
to make a choice between beat it's just
just
anytime you hear rumblings between
players that to me just
blow it up early because it can't get
any better and then you see in the
playoffs
with indeed by itself you can't do it so
you're going to have to figure something
out but definitely start with whoever
they keep with those two
or one or the other they're going to
have to get some shooting around that
individual
kobe would have turned 42 yesterday
what's your favorite memory about him
man i got so many uh just just
just uh just the rivalry you know we
used to talk about that a lot
and and he understood and the reason why
he was so great
was because he understood that he's one
shot away from losing
he respected every opponent
that's why he treated them all as if he
was playing against jordan or byrd or
the best
and so my favorite memories are just
being around him talking basketball or
hearing a little snide remark about the
kings from who's slipping and i'm
like what you just said
those two things and then um just loved
watching them mature after you know us
athletes
you you know we're all our families
support us so much and
you know you know uh they from what you
being on the road they support us so
much and so after
retirement you just want to give back so
much to him and it's just uh i knew he
was
looking forward to this part of his life
to spend with his family
i still find that amazing when he put up
81 on the raptors then he went to dinner
and jalen rose was with him or he went
to dinner with jaylen rose
and jalen was on the raptors and kobe
ordered a martini and he asked for 81
olives did you ever hear that story no
but that's cool
[Laughter]
uh great to see you i hope you're doing
well in the bubble there uh c
webb will be uh let's see game four
tonight lakers in the blazers that's at
nine eastern on uh tnt with brian
anderson
uh great talk to you c webb hey thanks a
lot thanks for having me all right